at the start of russia's invasion of
ukraine all predictions pointed towards
the same thing after the ballistic
missile barrage on airports and military
positions the russian air force will
quickly swoop in destroy the remaining
ukrainian air force and air defenses and
establish full superiority in the air
however 18 days into the war russia
still hasn't achieved their superiority
in fact they aren't even close to it on
top of that just their visually
confirmed losses add up to 12 planes 6
uavs and 15 helicopters i repeat these
are just the visually confirmed ones the
real numbers are higher meanwhile
according to u.s officials 80 percent of
ukraine's fixed-wing assets are still
intact and ukrainian air defenses are
still shooting down planes helicopters
and missiles ukrainian air forces and
air defenses aren't only surviving but
succeeding against the russian air force
which is 10 times their size so what's
going on here how is this even possible
ukrainians don't have flying tractors
after all here are the main reasons for
the russian air force's spectacular
failure number one smart ukrainian
maneuvering ukrainians have been
shuffling their assets around in a very
effective manner ever since the start of
the war this is why the russians initial
rocket barrage didn't break them and is
a major factor in the russian air force
being virtually ineffective against them
all this relates to reason number two
terrible russian equipment or the lack
thereof there are pictures floating
around defense blogs showing russian
pilots in jets above syria using
commercial gps units in the cockpit
things like this are a huge red flag
indicating massive problems with russian
equipment even prior to ukraine's
invasion not only that but ukrainians
also recovered pieces of paper from
downed russian jets with strike
coordinates written on them that's right
russian pilots are given pieces of paper
before takeoff but when they get there
ukrainians will have moved away already
and the pilot has nothing to strike and
then some of them get shot down by
ukrainian air defenses and so reason
number three is the lack of proper
training for pilots russian pilots fly
far less than nato pilots half as much
in fact and don't practice any complex
maneuvers beyond flying in pairs and
hitting the occasional ground targets
this is what they did in syria as well
but what works against rebel militias
won't work against a modern mechanized
opponent with proper air defenses this
relates to reason number 4 russian
inability to organize on a large scale
to establish dominance over the
ukrainian sky russians would need very
complex massive air maneuvers
coordinating a large number of aircraft
at the same time and they are just not
able to do that russians don't have the
experience or the knowledge to pull off
such actions instead they do the same
thing in the air as they do on the
ground in lieu of proper planning and
organization they just throw more
soldiers and equipment at the problem
hoping the ukrainians will eventually
buckle but it seems like this will not
happen consequently the ukrainians are
able to hold off the russians and cause
significant losses this is why russians
don't have their superiority after 18
days and most likely won't be able to
achieve it period now some people might
come in and say not so fast the russians
must be saving their strength for the
real air campaign which is definitely
coming operation godot is imminent where
the ukrainians will get wiped out we've
all heard people saying this but this is
a bad assessment as a rule of thumb if
russia could have established their
superiority they would have done so
already but they cannot so they did not
due to reasons detail in this video i
hope this little blurb from me helped
people better understand the war
situation in ukraine in the meantime you
can support me on patreon if you so
choose and i thank you for watching stay
tuned for more coverage of the ukrainian
invasion in the near future and i'll be
seeing you next time